es el preferido por beijing para dirigir
hong kong johnnie de 64 años se dispone
a tomar el timón de la metrópoli
asiática
debemos consolidar el estatus de hong
kong como ciudad internacional y poner a
disposición del mundo todas sus ventajas
de libertad de apertura
debemos integrar a hong kong en el
desarrollo nacional de china y
aprovechar estas oportunidades para
avanzar y se desempeñó como jefe de
seguridad en la época de las protestas
prodemocráticas en 2019 fue la figura
detrás de la violenta represión de los
manifestantes su reputación de mano dura
le ha dado la confianza a diferencia de
sus predecesores y no procede de un
entorno empresarial católico de
educación creció en un barrio popular de
la metrópoli después de 35 años en el
cuerpo de policía y una temporada en el
servicio secreto y ocupa actualmente
varios puestos de poder en el consejo
ejecutivo de hong kong john lee será
nombrado el jefe ejecutivo por un comité
en beijing el domingo el único candidato
a suceder a carril am en el 25
aniversario de hong kong para conmemorar
la entrega de la antigua colonia
británica a china